Bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin Nurana Abdi.
Ich bin die Diensthabende erst in der Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstand?
Ja.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar allgemeine
Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Okay?
Ja.
Und wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie zwischendurch oder am Ende des Gesprächs Ihre
Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Petra Gundlach.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachname burschen?
Petra P-E-T-R-A.
Petra.
Petra, ja.
Und wenn Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen?
Gundlach mit G-U-N-D-L-A-C-H.
Okay.
Frau Gundlach.
Ja.
Frau Gundlach, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 51 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Um 17. März 1971.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,67 m groß und ich wiege 84 kg.
Ja, und 80 kg.
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Okay.
Und was sind Sie vom Büro?
Ich arbeite in einem Büro in der Verwaltung.
Sie arbeiten in Verwaltungsamts?
Ja, in einer Verwaltung in einem Büro bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Okay.
Frau Gundlach, was führt Sie so und was will Sie besprechen?
Ja, ich habe so seit gut fünf Stunden,
habe ich jetzt ganz starke Bauchschmerzen.
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Können Sie bitte zeigen oder sagen?
Wo die Schmerzen genau sind, die sind mehr so im oberen Bauch,
so unter den Rippen,
mehr so in dem Bereich, nicht unten.
Mietig oder links?
Hauptsächlich die in der Mitte,
aber sie gehen auch so in den Rücken rein,
strahlen in den Rücken aus.
Okay.
Wann genau sind diese Schmerzen aufgezwitten?
Ja, ungefähr vor fünf Stunden.
Und wie sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz von ein bis zehn?
Wenn ein sehr leichter Schmerz ist,
dann ist es ein unerträglicher Schmerz.
Oh, da sind Sie, es geht so ein bisschen,
es wechselt etwas so zwischen sechs und neun.
Zwischen sechs und neun.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ja, sie sind mehr so drückend, so ganz dumpf.
Aber manchmal werden sie stärker, manchmal.
Dann werden sie eben so stark wie so stärken neun.
Aber sie sind dumpf.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen,
strahlen in den Rücken aus.
Sie haben sie hinten in den Rücken rein.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas gemacht, um die Schmerzen zu linden?
Ich habe mal im Anfang eine Wärmflasche genommen.
Hat das Ihnen geholt?
Nein, war nicht so gut, war eher schlechter.
Sind die Schmerzen abhängig mit Ihrem Lagerung?
Am liebsten möchte ich eher sitzen und ein bisschen nach vorne gebeucht sitzen.
Mich nicht groß bewegen.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden,
dass wichtig sein könnte?
Mir ist übel, ich habe dreimal gebrochen.
Mir ist schwindelig.
Ich habe auch Schweißausbrüche.
Aber ich habe Fieber gemessen, ich habe kein Fieber.
Kein Fieber.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Massalasen oder Stülgank?
Nein, das letzte Mal auf der Toilette,
vielleicht vor zwölf Stunden, das war in Ordnung.
Aber nichts.
Normal Stülgank.
Keine Durchfallkunde.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit stark ab oder zu genut?
Nein, ich habe sehr viel Gewicht, 84 kg für meine Körpergröße.
Aber ich habe in letzter Zeit keine Veränderung im Gewicht gehabt.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Oder haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen?
Malerweise kann ich gut schlafen, aber wenn es jetzt so warm ist,
nachts und so heiß ist, dann kann ich nicht so gut schlafen.
Aber das geht vielen Menschen.
Das ist für uns auch gültig.
Frau Gundlach, ich möchte über Ihre Vorgesteile fragen.
Was verstehen Sie unter diesen Vorerkrankungen?
Ich habe seit ungefähr zehn Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Dann habe ich auch hohe Blutfette.
Der Arzt sagt, die sind zu hoch, dann nehme ich auch etwas vereinen.
Ich habe auch seit zwei Jahren erhöhten Zucker.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme für den Blutdruck ein Moment.
Der Blutdruck steht hinter 5 mg.
Eine Tablette morgens und eine halbe Tablette abends.
Ich nehme für den Blutdruck ein 10 mg.
Eine Tablette abends.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Zuckerkrankheit?
Ich nehme für den Blutdruck eine halbe Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Vertragen Sie diese Medikamente gut?
Ja, Sie haben auch schon eine Verbesserung gebracht.
Frau Bundler, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind war das.
Da hatte ich einen Leistenbruch.
Ein Leistenbruch links.
Da war ich 11 Jahre alt.
Und ich war da eine Mandeloperation.
Da war ich 8 Jahre alt.
Und reagieren Sie allergisch?
Irgendwelche Medikamente, Lebensmittel?
Nein, allergien habe ich nicht.
Vertragen Sie alle Lebensmittel?
Ja, ich soll nicht alle Lebensmittel essen.
Ich habe ein Leistenbruch mit meinem Gewicht, aber ich vertrage alle.
Frau Bundler, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie üben.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Ja, dreimal habe ich erbrochen.
Wie sah das Erbrochene aus?
Das war ein bisschen gelbgrün.
Okay.
Haben Sie Blut gemacht?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona-Württemberg und Kinderkrankheiten?
Ich bin dreimal geimpft gegen Corona.
Die anderen Impfungen mache ich auch immer regelmäßig beim Hausarzt.
Dann sagt er mir, wenn etwas notwendig ist.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich habe im letzten Land verreist.
Frau Bundler, rauchen Sie?
Ja, am Wochenende vielleicht mal ein oder zwei Zigaretten.
Wenn das Essen gut geschmeckt hat, dann rauche ich mal eine Zigarette.
Aber nicht jeden Tag.
Eine Zigarette?
Ja, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, mal ein Bier, aber das ist auch nicht jeden Tag.
Vielleicht pro Woche eine Flasche.
Eine Flasche Bier pro Woche.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, Frau Bundler.
Ich muss auch diese Frage stellen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie einen Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und bekommen Sie noch regelmäßig?
Ja, aber nicht mehr so regelmäßig.
In den letzten zwei Jahren ist es unregelmäßig.
Aber ich gehe regelmäßig zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung bei der Frauenherz.
Ja, das ist sehr schön.
Sie müssen regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt gehen.
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig.
Und gibt es in Ihrer näheren Familie,
irgendwelche Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, mein Vater, der ist 79 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch Alterszucker und hat auch etwas hohen Blutdruck und hat Gicht.
Und Mutter hat ganz Brüche geknocken.
Sie hat ganz oft Knochenbrüche.
Sie sind sehr empfindlich, sehr brüchig.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Schwester, die ist 53 Jahre alt.
Sie ist gesund.
Sie hatte vor einem Jahr eine Gallenstein-OP.
Und Sie haben zwei Kinder, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die Kinder sind gesund.
Haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit?
Stress?
Ja.
Die Arbeit ist anstrengend, aber die Arbeit macht mir Spaß.
Nein, sonst ist es eine gute Arbeitsstelle.
Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Die Kinder wohnen nicht mehr bei uns.
Wohnen Sie in einer Wohnung?
In einer Wohnung.
Haben Sie Hausdiener?
Wir haben eine Katze.
Die Katze wird aber auch regelmäßig beim Tierarzt untersucht.
Wie ernähren Sie sich?
Der Arzt sagt, er esse zu viel.
Deswegen wiege ich so viel.
Ich soll Gewicht abnehmen.
Aber das fällt mir schwer.
Ich esse gemischte Kost.
Ich esse auch mal Fleisch, Gemüse, Kartoffeln, Reis.
Ich esse auch mal Kuchen.
Das ist nicht gut für den Zucker.
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie gleich Konsum reduzieren werden.
Das höre ich überall.
Das sehe ich auch im Fernsehen.
Es fällt mir schwer.
Frau Gunpla, ich habe alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Was kann das sein, dieser starken Schmerz?
Ich habe den noch nie vorher so gehabt.
Frau Gunpla, wir als Erste haben immer drei Schritte.
Zuerst haben wir eine körperliche Unterdrückung.
Und eine operative Diagnostik, Laborunterdrückung.
Jetzt habe ich auch einen Verdacht.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Bauchspeicherlbrüse entzündet.
Aber das ist nur eine kleine Frage.
Ich habe auch eine kleine Frage.
Ich habe eine kleine Frage.
Das ist nur ein Verdacht.
Das muss noch bestätigt werden.
Kann ich jetzt was trinken und was essen?
Es wäre besser, Sie auf Essen unterdenken, versichten.
Sie dürfen nichts essen und trinken.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Brauchen Sie wieder fünf Minuten zum Schreiben?
Hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
Nein, so was habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe die Schmerzen nicht mehr gegessen.
Ich habe sie nicht mehr gegessen.
Mir ist ja übel und ich habe auch erbrochen.
Ich habe nichts mehr gegessen.
Ich habe in Ordnung jetzt auch keinen richtigen Hunger.
Ich habe etwas Durst.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn noch etwas Durst?
Ich habe es nicht mehr gegessen.
Ich habe es noch nie gegessen.
Ich habe etwas Durst.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn noch einmal Stuhlgang oder Gehenwind ab?
Nein, Stuhlgang habe ich zuletzt vor zwölf Stunden gehabt.
Ich habe es noch nie gegessen.
Machen wir eine kleine Pause?
Ich komme wieder.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, gerne.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte über einen neuen Patienten berichten.
Darf ich?
Bitte.
Frau Petra Guntlach ist eine 51-jährige Patientin.
Sie hat sich in unseren Nothaufnahmen vorgestellt.
Die Patientin stellte sich wegen der Zeit 5 Stunden.
Sie hat sich bei der Zeit 5 Stunden vorgestellt.
Er ist gelbgründig.
Ja, sei gelbgründig, ja.
Und an Vorerkrankungen ergab sich Arterelle Hüphertone seit 10 Jahren.
Hüphert liebt die Deme seit 10 Jahren und Diabetes mehlitzt sie seit 2 Jahren.
Und sie nehme Kandysartan 5 mg, eine Morgens und eine halbe Abends.
Sie mastatin 10 mg eine Abends.
Mit von 1850 mg halbe Tablette Morgens und eine Abends.
Hat die Patientin so eine Schmerzsymptomatik schon einmal gehabt?
Nein, noch nie. Sie habe durch eine Schmerz noch nie gehabt.
Mit 11 Jahren wurde sie an Leistenhänni-Links operiert.
Mit Alter von 8 wurde sie tonselektomiert.
Mit 2 Zigarette am Wochenende bejaht.
Aber ein Nikotin-Abusus ist das sicherlich noch nicht.
Wir können nicht als Nikotin-Abusus bezeichnen.
Gelegentlicher Nikotinkonsum am Wochenende.
Wie steht es mit Alkohol?
Sie trinken gelegentlich eine Fläche via Proboche.
Das ist ja auch nicht so viel.
Drogenabusus wurde verneint.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familie?
Ja, in der Familienanamese befand sich Diabetes Melitus, Brut, Arteriele, Hypertony,
Gicht beim Vater und Frakturen bei der Mutter.
Osteoporose?
Und Kolelithiasis bei der Schwester.
Gibt es bei der Patientin Gallenstahne bekannt?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die Diabetes.
Wie ist es mit einem Ulkostodene?
Der Ulkostodene muss auch geschlossen werden.
Stimme ich Ihnen zu.
Wie wollen Sie weiter vorgehen?
Ich fahre weiter Abklärung.
Und eine Infusion wegen der Diabetes?
Ich empfehle eine Menöse und eine Infusion.
Und bildgebende Verfahren?
Zuerst würde ich Ultraschallunterzulung durchführen.
Und Röntgenaufnahme.
Und eine EKG?
Bei der Ultraschallunterzulung des Abdomens kann es sein, dass es schwierig wird.
Die Patientin ist, wie ich gesehen habe, adipös.
Wir können Computerpomographie machen.
Aber zuerst die von Ihnen empfohlenen Untersuchungsgänge, Sonografie, Labor, Infusion,
Venöserzugang, Schmerztherapie und Antibiotische Therapie.
Ich bin auf Ihrer Linie auf Pankreatitis.
Und von Alkoholabusos, wie die Patientin das zumindest schildert.
Sondern eventuell kann es auch sein, dass die Patientin Galenstein hat.
Und dann kommt zu einem Galenstein, der an der Papille sitzt und zu einer Pankreatitis geführt hat.
Ich bin einverstanden und kann gut folgen.
Ich bin auch einverstanden, wie Sie die Anamese erhoben haben.
Das war sehr gut, sprachlich sehr gut, sehr strukturiert.
Und wie Sie auch das Angebot gemacht haben mit Fragen stellen und so weiter, das war alles in Ordnung.
Nachgefragt hätte ich vielleicht noch, als die Patientin gesagt hat, meine Schwester wurde an der Galenblase operiert.
Vielleicht kurz Fragen, sind bei Ihnen denn Galensteine bekannt?
Ja, die haben recht.
Die Galensteine sind bei mir schon fünf Jahre bekannt, hätte ich als Patientin dann geantwortet.
Und bisher aber haben wir uns noch nicht entschlossen, was zu tun.
Und bisher haben Sie auch keine Symptome gemacht.
Aber seit fünf Jahren weiß ich, dass ich Galensteine habe.
Gut, aber so haben Sie das finde ich sehr gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Wann haben Sie Prüfung?
22. Oktober.
Oktober erst, ja.
Was wollen Sie denn da noch üben?
Sie haben, ja, immer ein bisschen trainieren, aber das ist doch schon sehr gut.
Ja.
Vielen Dank.